Ali Hashim Al jaaz D South
Lebanon now the UK's foreign minister
was forced to run for cover during a
visit to Southern Israel on Wednesday
Israel's foreign Ministry released this
footage showing James cleverly and
government officials Hing hurrying
indoors in ofakim cleverly offered
solidarity with Israel and says he hoped
civilian casualties could be
minimized for more on the UK's stance on
the war in Israel here's NE Baka
reporting from London Britain's foreign
secretary James cleverly was in Israel
to continue showing Britain's
unequivocal support for the Israeli
government this after prime minister
Rishi sunak said if asked he would be
prepared to provide Israel with
intelligence with security and with
diplomatic support James cleverly met
with survivors of the Hamas attack and
also with leading lawmakers and at one
point was forced to take cover with his
Israeli counterpart Eli Cohen when air
raid sirens went off but cleverly along
with the whole of the British government
is under a tremendous amount of pressure
to underline exactly what its
humanitarian conditions are this after
Israel blockaded the flow of uh food of
medicine and fuel to Gaza something that
of course will have a huge impact on
people on the ground there and as the
head of amnesty UK said it is entirely
right that cleverly is offering his
report to Israeli civilians who've
suffered in these completely appalling
attacks but Mr cleverly should also be
urging all parties to the conflict
including the Israeli authorities to
respect International humanitarian law
earlier in the week the British prime
minister Rishi sunak spoke at a
synagogue in North London where he said
there are not two sides to these events
there cannot be a question of balance
this of course as 17 British Nationals
including children are feared killed as
a result of hamas's actions Hamas was
prescribed a ter as a terrorist
organization here in the UK a few years
ago and as a result Britain's Home
Secretary sella braan has warned that
any protesters waving Palestinian Flags
or singing Pro Palestinian songs could
well face arrest if it could it's deemed
that they are doing that in support of
Hamas a move that has riled an awful lot
of people who feel that that will only
deepen the division between opposing
views about why this conflict is
happening at all NE marker Al jazer
London now rallies in support of
Palestinians have taken place around the
world in the United States there were
marches in dozens of towns and cities
with one of the biggests in Chicago
hundreds turned out in Chile's Capital
Santiago which has the largest
Palestinian Community outside the Middle
East and in South Africa protests is
compared the 75 year illegal occupation
of Palestine to the Injustice of
apartheid in their
country if we are against white
supremacy and colonialism all over the
world we have to support the demands for
the Palestinian people to and the fight
for decolonization and the fight against
white supremacist Zionist Israel that is
occupying stolen land that belonged to
the indigenous people of
Palestine
there has always been a bond with our
homeland and we come here in an Act of
Faith and solidarity with our people
with the people who are indiscriminately
dying today in Palestine by the attacks
from the Israeli occupation Army in
France police in the city of Leon used
Force to break up a March in support of
Palestinians on Wednesday City officials
banned Gatherings plann for later in the
week authorities also imposed bans on
Pro Palestinian rallies French president
Emanuel mcon has has condemned hamas's
attack on Israel but opposes freezing EU
humanitarian assistance to the
Palestinians Pro Palestinian
demonstrations have also been held in
Germany's capital Berlin with a large
police presence Melissa Chan has
more police have just told everyone in
the area to disperse they have banned
all Palestinian solidarity protests over
the next few days uh particularly in
Germany this is a touchy subject because
of the history of the country
the history of World War II and the
Nazis and the Holocaust which means that
the German government and the German
people many of them consider something
as simple as waving the Palestinian flag
as
anti-semitic this is just you know this
is always the flag and the old German
argument to denounce and actually
prosecute Palestinian voices for the
rights in Palestine Palestines also have
the right to do whatever they want they
have been paying for 75 years and that's
not okay now over the next few days
emotions are going to run High there's
also a big Israeli Community here and
police say one reason why they're
banning protests is to prevent the two
sides from clashing Melissa Chan Al
jazer
Berlin I show you